[Music]
and three college news oh I heard about
this recall how's that possible somebody
gotta be paying for it submitted by Joe
Molly injustice student Oh
New York makes tuition free but students
must stay after God how the funding I'll
do that you know how many colleges New
York has get to stay in New York New
York State or New York City State okay
so every college in New York can be free
as long as you stay there this is
specific for middle class students it's
awesome what about the poor ones
I am financial aid oh yeah that's true
middle class before [ __ ] the most [ __ ]
what it sucks to be middle class because
you got [ __ ] pay for everything and
you end up like worse than broke people
or rich people yeah I heard being real
constabulary sauce all my friends are
middle class they will always complain
Tibet to pay like so much money a full
price for college and I was like haha
that's when I get the last laugh [ __ ]
you get your dad buys your [ __ ] car
but guess what I don't have to pay for
school [ __ ] where did you sit
either your friends I said it in my head
gee oh yeah those like middle class
people do we have college funds only
yeah they're responsible
there was possible parents do that it
sucks to be responsible so this is what
does my game plan be poor until your
kids are out of college oh shut up to
the nephew he got into UCI good job
congratulations how do you Matthew you
killed it thought it was look yesterday
Isaac came home with like a whole
pocketful of change from his book for
Eric to be on stream oh cool he's like
mommy where's my college fund I want to
put it in my college fund
I better go to college you're gonna be
an actor no he's like I want to go to
college mommy can save this money for me
and I'm like thank you so much I'm you
suck it any popular with it like how to
create your own Bank you'd be
responsible for your own money so then
you found a water bottle using all right
thanks stupid key cracking that took a
dark turn source crackling you're weird
you feelin rolling around in the room
exactly what my kid I just wanted to be
one of the King Philip lackeys won't
allow you can you know what the [ __ ] do
a mother turn to a chance yeah when the
parcel yeah yeah okay anyways New York
they're implementing this initiative is
college tuition initiative and so family
is earning a hundred and twenty five
thousand dollars or less can qualify for
this and so what it is it's like forever
for however long you go to college and
you get that education for free that's
how much longer you have to stay after
you graduate why do you want them to
stay in New York because they want you
they want them to bring the pallet back
to the state yeah and then like tell us
to like help the economy like pretty
much the education that they get now
when you're in the workforce and you how
to bring it back here you get tasks on
your salary that tax goes right back
into the state exactly yeah that's smart
that is a great incentive yes they're
saying like why should be yorkers pay
for college education and then you just
pick up and move to california once
you're done maybe she's gotta be so
expensive live at so they can live there
no this is cut new york state it's
different from New York City because if
they're like upstate or whatever but
everywhere else
I thought that ass no one likes with
Buffalo New York oh my god those ways
are delicious but your place sucks
that's probably why they're going to pay
for their college they want you to stay
in New York today yeah exactly so if you
guys like a four-year college and you
get all those four years for free and
you have to stay in the state for
another four you good commitment that's
pretty cool that's worth it go to NYU
for four years you just kind of stayed
north for years let's please oh yeah
you're still [ __ ] youngest [ __ ] yeah
so I would have stayed like a couple
years after my college around my college
anyways if I could is get established
get a job you know I actually think this
is better than a really similar to the
military option so the military if you
do like ROTC or whatever and you get
like two or four years pay for then
right after you have to serve two or
four years but in the military like
you're shipped off random places
constantly there's really no stability
and you also get to lose out on civilian
life so this is another option if you
want somewhere to pay for your college
you can still be a regular civilian and
not have to go in the middle of nowhere
that's pretty awesome question you know
one that we had a draft what what age
did that stop at does
35 or so I think to me five Danis hella
late yeah [ __ ] why not look it like 30 I
think when you're 35 they still
considered you like very able bodies
what if you're like really overweight
the world depends on your medical health
too like you can't be obese and be like
the wrong direction bro yeah that Kaiser
real quick I'll to be a year Freight
it's gonna happen well you're good
though I just some videos of you playing
basketball a lot I'll show my ankles I
guess x-rays I being if we're gonna
fight like going to World War three or
something and there's a draft who's
wondering I don't know I got financial
aid I got a duty to this nation so
you're joining your government well I
mean I'm drafted right so I feel like if
you wouldn't have escaped it depends on
who the leader is and what did I just go
from I got financial aid io do the IO
duties to this nation well okay what if
we had a Hitler what about the realistic
situation like right now because people
are talking about what's it done okay
and then Donald Trump goes I'm
activating all the people that are under
35 that now whatever has to go right do
I still got JK yes I got a duty to the
station to [ __ ] tell the news that's
the duty a time nobody in there all
right like let's say this is this is
like World War three and it's like the
last like wave of people I see twice I
have to do it oh that's the mo cuz it is
different is different from like the
first wave with people the first wave
it's like let's just let the soldiers do
their [ __ ] they train for the champagne
then it's the second wave and then they
go we don't have enough people then
we're getting the grandpas with the
pitchforks you know it's kind of it's
like the movies the last resort I'm a
part of the last resort group but I'm
down to do it I got financial aid people
dress women to at this point and I don't
know I'm not just well word I heard is
that Senate passed it I don't know what
the House of Reps passed it even to I
don't remember yeah I just don't want to
go to war man I support our troops a
hundred percent but you guys are trained
human beings like I'll train you
alright you can't train this you don't
have you can opt out to be medic you go
out you could go I can be a shell out to
kill people yeah you could
against religion because I think there
was one group of Christian I don't know
if they were like I can't kill people I
say it all the time verbally I can't
kill somebody dude I can't but yeah but
if it's also against your religion - you
could say you know it's against my
religion to kill so I rather be a medic
here let me cook for you do you have
your kimchi fried rice every day son but
then you're still going to warn you have
to run and [ __ ] save people what
bullets are flying in [ __ ] while cooking
cooking she keeps trying to get you to
be a medic cooking in the field yeah
yeah you're like [ __ ] cooking and
then a [ __ ] bomb hit your cap and
[ __ ] I just I get the like war
just chill out nothing's happening it I
know I'm just saying are toss the world
on their arm
I thought your Park masters North Korea
like defang [ __ ] you and then Trump is
like oh yeah and we're sending some
ships over there they're sending ships
to [ __ ] this tension there's a lot of
tension right now that's why I love our
troops so much because you guys are such
brave human beings but you guys there's
a very specific type of mindset to be
able to do that you know what I mean
paramilitary kicks [ __ ] ass and also
I'm not really trying to kiss right now
no but I'm just saying like to send
someone like me out you already this war
is not going to be well okey though if
you could kill legally whatever cool I
guess that would be cool no it's just
kind of like hard for me to really think
about me killing somebody like legit
especially somebody I don't know and I
don't have a real like ready data
against you know what I mean oh I like
watching the movie the purge I was just
like I could never do that
I don't hate and you don't have to hate
to hurt that's wrong you're a black
mirror episode with the soldiers has a
good [ __ ] that would be okay is it
has to do with we're talking about right
now but I don't want to really cook like
the purge right so that's like there's
one day where you could kill and do
whatever well I have a whole years worth
of this person that I [ __ ] hate and I
want this scum off the face of this firm
they're motivated to killing cuz you
hate someone is wrong one yeah thanks
for one of the reasons would you kill
someone it's kind of like sport fighting
you know like when you when you fight in
sport you're doing it because you don't
hate them and the other person is in the
sport with you - yeah well that's what
war is right you don't hate them
you don't personally hate this person
this person of course you hate them
you've been brainwashed I don't hate
anybody like you
in there I'm pretty sure these soldiers
don't hate the people that they're out
to like whatever how can they kill them
without having that what I'm saying is
you don't have to have hate to in order
to kill I think it's wrong to hate
somebody you want to kill like kill them
because you hate someone because that's
like losing self-control but if you're
killing because it's a duty then that's
very different
you think that's that's like easier to
live with no what do you mean like you
can live with yourself knowing like I
killed that person just because that's
the way it is not even hate that person
I think it's harder for me to kill
someone if I if I hate them
like no I can do it but then I know it's
it's because I lost self-control
emotionally versus if it was my job to
be a soldier I'm just killing someone
because that's the law of the land it's
so scary cuz it's like I feel like
sometimes I have my tax dollars that pay
for the military but then now I had to
be a part of nowhere else I go yeah can
I get that money back says my [ __ ] I am
I gonna be on no edition give me my
money back
I got a gardener right yeah hit his
[ __ ] all the time and also he's
like and I might need some help and I'm
like well I paid well gee ha ha ha ha
how do you guys feel about the fact that
like a lot of the u.s. budget goes
towards military rather than education
like what we're talking about here where
they're providing free tuition to
educate these people but like most of
the money in the budget goes to military
that's a hard one for sure I think we
all have like a lot of qualms about that
I think in America it's very apparent
that we have a lot of high taxation but
we don't see where it goes
yeah you know and that's like our
biggest issues but at the same time you
have to realize this country is also a
huge huge power yeah the reason why is
because of that military and if it's not
the United States it will be another
contact I wish that we get a lot of nice
things here like unnecessary evil to the
United States they need on their go
someone a parent now
yeah they got to spend all that money on
the military so they can position
themselves where they want to in the
world but then it does suck out on the
education but I'm glad that like states
like New York are kind of taken into
their own hands and
like well if you don't have federal
backing at least we can do what we can
do as a state yeah
I love the opportunities this country
has thank you for watching just kidding
News and to follow us on The Daily go on
Instagram and follow us at just kidding
news for the last video click over here
[Music]